>> GRAND JURY AND THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA TODAY
RETURNED AN INDICTMENT
PRESENTED BY THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S OFFICE.
THE INDICTMENT CHARGES 13
RUSSIAN NATIONALS AND THREE
RUSSIAN COMPANIES FOR
COMMITTING FEDERAL CRIMES
WHILE SEEKING TO INTERFERE
IN THE UNITED STATES
POLITICAL SYSTEM INCLUDING
THE 2016 PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
WITH THE STATED GOAL OF
SPREADING DISTRUST TOWARDS
THE CANDIDATES AND THE
POLITICAL SYSTEM IN GENERAL.
NOW, THERE IS NO ALLEGATION
IN THIS INDICTMENT THAT ANY
AMERICAN WAS A KNOWING
PARTICIPANT IN THIS ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY.
THERE IS NO ALLEGATION IN
THE INDICTMENT THAT THE
CHARGED CONDUCT ALTERED THE
OUTCOME OF THE 2016
ELECTION.
>> A ROCKING NEWS DAY HERE
IN WASHINGTON ON A FRIDAY.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL
BYRON YORK CHIEF POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT OF THE
WASHINGTON EXAMINER.
MARIE HARF A FORMER
SPOKESPERSON AT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT.
THE HILL.
GENTLEMEN, LADY, GOOD
EVENING.
>> HELLO.
>> Mike: YOUR REACTION TO
WHAT YOU HEARD THERE, THESE
DIMES TODAY.
>> IT'S RATHER SHOCKING.
EVERYTHING ABOUT IT IS
SHOCKING.
IT'S SHOCKING TO SEAT DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO ME
MAKING THAT ANNOUNCEMENT.
IT DIDN'T COME SPECIFICALLY
FROM THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
TEAM.
IT IS SHOCKING THAT WHAT
THEY ARE SAYING IS THAT
THESE REALLY INTERESTING
THEY SAID THESE RUSSIANS
WERE SPREADING DISCORD.
THESE ARE SERIOUS CHARGES
BUT THAT WAS A STRANGE WORD
TO T. SEEMED TO USE.
IT'S WEIRD THEY SAID THEY
HAVE BEEN DOING IT FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS EVEN BEFORE
THIS ELECTION ELECTION
CYCLE.
IT DIDN'T SEEM LIKE THAT
INGENIOUS A PLAN TO GET ON
TWITTER AND START TO, YOU
KNOW, SAY BAD THINGS ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON.
AND OTHER CANDIDATES AND I
THINK FOR A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS, THEY ARE KIND
OF SINGING THAT SONG AFTER
ALL OF THIS IS THAT ALL
THERE IS?
AND IF THAT REALLY IS ALL
THERE IS, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO WANT TO
MOVE ON.
>> Mike: MARIE, YOU HAVE A
DIPLOMATIC BACKGROUND.
HOW SURPRISED WERE YOU BY
WHAT YOU HEARD TODAY.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT'S ALL
THERE IS.
I THINK IT'S THE LATEST
ROUND AND CLEAR BOB MUELLER
IS PULLING AT A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THREADS HERE.
REALLY OUTLINES FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE THE EXTENT
IN THIS ONE PIECE OF RUSSIA
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD
BE CONCERNED THAT THEY MAY
HAVE SEEN SOCIAL MEDIA POSTS
THAT WERE DISINFORMATION
FROM RUSSIANS THAT THEY MAY
HAVE ATTENDED RALLIES
ORGANIZED BY THESE RUSSIANS
BOTS.
I THINK FOR A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE UNDERSCORES THE
PEOPLE THAT THIS IS NOT A
HOAX.
THE RUSSIAN MEDDLING WAS AND
IS REAL.
THIS WEEK YOU HAD THE
INTELLIGENCE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEFS UP ON
THE HILL SAYING THEY ARE
STILL TRYING TO DO THIS IN
2018 AND 2020.
IT IS A SERIOUS ONGOING
THREAT THAT NEEDS TO BE
TREATED THAT WAY BY THE
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Mike: ANOTHER REVELATION
TODAY THAT THE RUSSIANS WERE
SO SNEAKY THEY WERE DOING
EVENTS FOR AND AGAINST
CANDIDATE TRUMP.
TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS.
>> Mike: AFTER THE ELECTION
THE DEFENDANTS ALLEGEDLY
STAGED RALLIES TO
PRESIDENT-ELECT WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY STAGING
RALLIES TO PROTEST HIS
ELECTION.
FOR EXAMPLE THE DEFENDANTS
ORGANIZED ONE RALLY TO
SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT-ELECT
AND ANOTHER RALLY TO OPPOSE
HIM.
BOTH IN NEW YORK ON THE SAME
DAY.
BYRON YOUR REACTION TO WHAT
YOU HEARD TODAY.
>> I THINK ACTUALLY WHAT
ROSENSTEIN SAID THERE
SUPPORTS THIS IDEA THAT THEY
WERE -- THERE WAS REALLY TWO
FOLD.
DISRUPT OUR SYSTEM, TO SOW
DISCORD AND TO MESS WITH
HILLARY CLINTON.
WHOM THEY THOUGHT WAS GOING
TO BE THE PRESIDENT.
AND SO THERE WERE LESSER
TARGETS.
BERNIE SANDERS.
THEY WANTED TO SUPPORT HIM
AND JILL STEIN THEY WANTED
TO SUPPORT HER.
BUT, AGAIN, THAT WAS ALL
KIND OF HILLARY-FOCUSED JUST
AS THEIR SUPPORT OF TRUMP
WAS.
THEN THE UNTHINKABLE
HAPPENS.
TRUMP WINS AND THEY JUST
BEGIN TO DISRUPT IN A
DIFFERENT WAY PUTTING ON TWO
RALLIES IN NEW YORK.
ONE A PRO-TRUMP RALLY AND
THE OTHER IS TRUMP IS NOT MY
PRESIDENT RALLY.
SO I THINK IT JUST SUPPORTS
THE IDEA THAT THEY WERE JUST
MESSING WITH THINGS THE
WHOLE TIME,.
>> MOSCOW.
KIND OF SURPRISING.
NONE OF THESE PEOPLE THAT
EXTRADITE THEM I DON'T
THINK.
PUT THEM ONS
PUT THEM ON NOTICE AND FOR A
RUSSIAN MEDDLING A HOAX,
RIGHT HE?
DOESN'T SEEM TO ACCEPT THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
ASSESSMENT BECAUSE WHAT THEY
NEED NEED TO BE DOING PLAN
TO APPRECIATE IT NEXT TIME.
AND THAT TESTIMONY THIS WEEK
FROM THE INTELLIGENCE CHIEF
14UD BE VERY SUNNY TO
AMERICANS.
FACEBOOK AND TWITTER A LOT
OF AMERICANS GET THEIR NEWS
FROM FACEBOOK AND TWITTER.
>> THIS IS RATHER ABSURD.
THIS IS LIKE ROCKY BULL
WINKLE KIND OF STUFF.
WHEN I THINK OF RUSSIAN
COLLUSION IN OUR ELECTIONS,
I AM OFFENDED.
I THINK IT'S REPULSIVE.
IS THIS WHAT IT WAS?
IT WAS 13 GUYS HAVING SOME
>> THERE IS GOING TO BE
MORE.
THIS ISN'T IT.
>> THIS IS CLEARLY THEIR
SHOT.
ACTING AS BOTS.
SOMEONE MIGHT HAVE READ
FACEBOOK POST INCORRECT.
IT'S REPUGNANT.
SHOULDN'T HAVE HAPPENED.
OBAMA SHOULD HAVE STOPPED IT
SAME TOKEN THIS IS NOT A
WORTH A YEAR OF THE
COUNTRY'S TIME OVER
EVERYTHING ELSE WE HAVE DEAL
WITH IN THIS COUNTRY AND
CHARGES OF RUSSIAN COLLUSION
HAS CLEARLY BEEN RIDICULOUS
AND NOT TRUE.
>> NOT A SURPRISE EITHER.
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEES
KNOWN ALMOST EVERYTHING IN
THIS INDICTMENT.
A LOT OF IT HAS ACTUALLY
BEEN REPORTED IN THE PRESS.
AND REMEMBER THERE WAS JUST
A HUGE EXCITEMENT OVER THE
FACEBOOK ADS A WHILE BACK
WITH THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEES.
WHICH REALLY ADDED UP TO
VERY, VERY LITTLE.
>> MOST OF THEM RAN AFTER
THE ELECTION.
>> Mike: FBI GOT A TIP ABOUT
THIS YOUNG MAN THAT FELL
THROUGH THE CRACKS.
AS A DAD I FIND THAT
PARTICULARLY DEVASTATING.
YOUR REACTION TO THAT, MATT?
>> YEAH, NO, I MEAN, LOOK,
LAW ENFORCEMENT THEY HAVE A
TOUGH JOB.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO CATCH
EVERY BAD PERSON THAT WANTS
TO DO HARM TO THIS SOCIETY.
THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO KNOW
THESE WERE NOT JUST SOMEBODY
SAYING SOMETHING BAD ABOUT A
GUY.
TELLING THEM CHAPTER AND
VERSE WHY THIS GUY WAS A
THREAT.
>> Mike: SHOULD SOMEBODY
LOSE THEIR JOB.
>> SOMEBODY PROBABLY SHOULD.
I DON'T THINK IT'S ONE
PERSON THOUGH.
THIS HAS TO BE A SYSTEMATIC
LOOK AT HOW WE GO ABOUT THIS
BECAUSE WE HAVE ALWAYS HEARD
IF YOU SEE SOMETHING, SAY
SOMETHING.
THERE ARE BAD PEOPLE OUT
THERE.
GO TO THE FBI BECAUSE YOU
TRUST.
TAKE A LOOK TOP TO BOTTOM
HOW THIS WAS HANDLED.
SOMEBODY PROBABLY SHOULD
LOSE THEIR JOB OVER.
THIS CAN'T BLAME IT ON ONE
PERSON.
WE NEED TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS.
LOOK AT GUN LAWS, LOOK AT
MENTAL HEALTH.
ALL OF IT IN THE WAKE OF
SOMETHING LIKE THIS BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO PREVENT THIS FROM
HAPPENING AGAIN.
>> Mike: BYRON.
>> FOR THE FBI ITSELF A LOT
OF REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN
VERY CRITICAL OF THE FBI'S
HANDLING OF HIGHLY
POLITICIZED INVESTIGATIONS.
THE CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION, THE
TRUMP-RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
AT THE SAME TIME, PRAISING
THE WORK THAT THE FBI DOES
AND FIGHTING CRIME AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
AND TO HAVE THIS HOREB DUST
MISTAKE HAPPEN IS REALLY
BAD.
>> Mike: A LOT OF FOLKS
BEHIND US ON CAPITOL HILL